la filière banane antillaise est une des
filières agricoles d'outre-mer les plus
subventionnés avec la canne sucre rhum
eredom République et développement
outre-mer s'est penché sur cette filière
et son fonctionnement
[Applaudissements]
le posé au programme d'option spécifique
à l'éloignement et l'insularité et la
déclinaison ultramarine du premier
pilier de la PAC ou politique agricole
commune dans les outre-mer depuis 2007
celui-ci représente 320 millions d'euros
par an et destiné aux agriculteurs de
l'ensemble des filières végétales et
animales
ultramarine
le premier constat est une répartition
inégale entre les filières avec 44% des
mesures en faveur des productions
agricoles soit 129 millions d'euros pour
la seule filière banane point important
cette aide est destination financer une
production de référence de 318000 tonnes
soit une aide de 440
cependant dans la réalité vient un
lobbying efficace de dérogations ont été
mises en place par rapport au pays
bananes dès 2007 dans le cas où la
production atteindrait 80% seulement les
318000 tonnes prévus 100% de l'aide sera
versée dans le cas d'aller à climatique
100% de l'aide sera versée quelle que
soit la production réelle or les aléas
climatiques représentent environ la
moitié des années aux Antilles la
subvention réelle est donc plus proche
des 600 euros la tonne pour 220 tonnes
réellement produites que des 480 euros
la tonne pour 318000 tonnes produites
initialement prévues
cela signifie donc sur la période 2007
2022 environ 1,5 millions de tonnes de
bananes n'ayant pas été réellement
produite ont été subventionnés pour un
montant d'environ 600 millions d'euros
cette répartition des aides se fait au
détriment des autres filières avec
seulement 10% des aides hors bananes et
Cannes sucres Rome destiné au reste des
productions végétales la répartition des
aides est également inégalitaire au sein
de la filière avec environ 80% de l'aide
ne bénéficions aux 20% des plus gros
producteurs les économies d'échelle dans
le cadre de la répartition des aides
contre les petits producteurs ont de
grandes difficultés à vivre de leur
production
ma situation actuellement dans la banane
c'est pas c'est pas la joie financière
au moins je me retrouve pas j'envoie de
la banane sous la métropole et chaque
fois que je reçois je reçois
les comptes de vote je suis pratiquement
débuter les emplois de la filière sont
passés de 12000 à 6000 entre 2007 et
2016 selon la DAF de la Martinique et le
nombre d'exploitations est passé de 520
à environ 350 aujourd'hui selon le d.a.m
pour la Martinique redom et donc
mobilisé pour améliorer la distribution
des aides agricoles du possible dans les
outre-mer avec un soutien réel à la
diversification de la production à la
production destinée à la consommation
locale dans un contexte de taux de
couverture très faible et de toute
importation
et au petit producteurs rejoignez-nous
et rejoignez notre combat en adhérent
[Applaudissements]